dylan cease has been red hot you look at
the starts this year this is his seventh
his era at 237 he's getting the ball
over the plate he's striking out a lot
of people left-handers because of that
change-up and his curveball hitting just
122. so he's had a beautiful run let's
see if he can keep it going lisa rise
off the injured list
2-2 struck him out dylan cease attacks
for his first strikeout right now when
you look at that curveball it's one of
the best curveballs in the game so what
dandy of a breaking ball the first one
he's thrown it could hardly be any
better than that two and two on nelson
cruz who's the best ops plus guy in this
lineup
there's strike three dylan
to the attic with a fastball and a one
two three first inning for dylan's seat
here's a look at
kenta maeda so far this year not up to
his
usual
self so far last outing very good though
that's a high slider and eaton deposits
it in left
[Applause]
boy kenta maeda right now it's a time to
get him see if the twins can do that the
white side did
liner and a double play
handleton simmons with the catch
and a quick release
to the first baseman osteo and maediff
gives up a hit but faces just three men
and now polanco
driven to right and polanco tees off and
has another home run and the twins
strike first one to nothing well
location location location that's a gift
and give polanco credit
it's a high fastball and it's popped up
watches it bounce and it's foul monkana
and grandall looked at each other and
both thought
they're gonna take charge and they just
sort of
let it fall
flared into short right and that'll die
for a hit
larnick to third base and that'll be
enough for him he had to wait and make
sure that ball was going to land so the
makings of a really big inning here
simmons
pop fly single into right and they're
loaded up now for ben roorkvet
and it hit him
an 02 breaking ball that hit him and
it's two to nothing kind of the dylan
cease that we've seen in the past great
stuff and just loses command
and that'll turn the light up over for
our eyes
right center field and eaton is there
for the catch
tagging from third
scoring is larnick and the throw to
third base he's out
simmons has thrown out a good one-hop
throw we believe the run has scored
but again we'll have to be at the mercy
yes the home plate umpire were able to
see
saying that warnick crossed the planer
excuse me ostadio crossed the plate for
the third run of the inning
3-2
yep down and out ball four he really
does fall in love with that slider on
three and two we've seen a boatload of
them today
and two on with nobody out for the white
sox with grand all coming up
yes money absolutely crushes it hand to
right field and bring him home we're
tied
that baseball was vaporized
for a three-run shot
so just like that
it's a brand new game tied at three
anderson had a long battle with maeda
then he hit a fly ball to kevin
and a base hit left field
vaughn
being waved around here's the throw from
left field and rorkvedt with the tag
luisa eyes with the throw from left
field to cut down the runner
here is larnick
it's a fastball and abreu takes away his
first major league hit
3-3 bottom three the sox will bat with
adam eaton monkana and abreu
and the split gets uh swinging strike
three playing his first strikeout of the
night now graves started the second
inning with a sharp single to left
center field
kepler back and over at the wall leaping
and making the catch
max kepler played center field there
like he's been there his entire career
played it perfectly for the third out
one and two still on ostedio
slider off with his head one gone
oh two
yeah that's a swing
it's not a good one but it counts
two out
fastball yes sir see you later dylan c
strikes out the side
struck him out fastball up and out of
the zone
two and two again
he struck him out on a change-up dylan
sees his struck out seven and a big one
there
it takes everybody swinging the bass
better than they have been as a line
that is to short center field a base hit
ostinio to third and he'll have to hold
up there
and right off the end of the bat
in the air short right field
eaton charging he's underneath and
ostedio is not going to tag
two gone the pinch hitter is wiped away
and so one out away from getting out
with a tie
filthy slider to the outside corner
one on one out for abreu
jose tags it left center field way back
gives the sox the lead it's five to
three
jose almost got one earlier he saves his
best for the twins he usually torments
this club
and he hit his seventh he's driven in 28
more important than that the sox have
the lead
tim would love that sixth run up there
tim to left field this is down
that was way inside and tim tore it to
left anyway
for a 6-3 lead
and tim looking to drive home a rod and
it's a big one oh and two from field bar
eating short right field garlic's got a
charge garlic is too short to make the
play anderson is coming home eaton's on
his way to third
and adam eaton ends up with three bases
as garlic came up just shy
on his dive in right it's 7-3
can't stay the way it was
left side that's through it's a
two-strike single for garcia and it's
run number eight here's madrigal
nikki two strikes welcome to the party
billy hamilton easily home
safe but third super joe went down he's
so excited it's 9-3 socks
two down tomorrow's coming fast ruiz for
kepler
first pitch hunting jose snares it and
in the first game between the sox and
twins it is the white sox scoring the
last nine
to beat minnesota and get win number 20.